also ich sage das erste was mir gegeben
hast erinnert mich vom geschmack her
mehr an die leute letzter ist der kanal
mega mitwächst skaliert deswegen bringt
es hat ein bisschen zurück in eine ganz
andere richtung und zwar kennt das jeder
jeder hat in seinem freundeskreis
verschiedene arten von leuten genau
genommen zwei arten von leuten wenn man
menschen hat die fast food mögen und
regelmäßig essen dann gibt es entweder
ein ex-liebhaber oder burger king
liebhaber haben wir testen heute ob
dieses ganze theater rund um mac osx und
burger king wirklich sinn macht oder ob
es eigentlich genau gleich schmeckt
während bei mcdonald's und burger king
und haben genau die gleichen sachen
eingekauft und zwar cheeseburger
schicken burger pommes und cola als und
werden vergleichen ob man blinden
unterschied feststellen kann
ok sebastian legt du bitte die
augenbinde an so leute dass sebastian
ich überlege mir was wir als erstes
nehmen
machen wir mal den absoluten klassiker
wo sie gleich auf die meinung relativ
gespalten nummer 1 und nummer 2
irgendwie einfach mal keine unterschiede
sebastian kann das leider nicht aber ich
[Musik]
hab's in die pommes latte gefahr dass er
wahrscheinlich ist dazu die größte
glaubensfragen ja wo sind die pommes
besser dass die beiden einander
verstehen was man ganz verzichten doch
mal entspannt ich bin auch richtig
gespannt aber das reck hat man die
kommentare wenn ihr gerade junge leute
und ja ich merke von chips in die pause
die rechte seite ist das schwierig ich
finde die hier die sind wie christian
was findest du erstmal besser was
schmeckt besser richtig hardcore krippe
sind wurde der bereich die hier sind
irgendwie ein bisschen die sind weicher
ich sage und die sind deutlich mehr
crispy diesen deutlich weicher ich
glaube
dass die crew speakers von max burger
king kommen sie weiter und deswegen sage
ich das ist burger king das merke ja
vielleicht sagen du liegt leider
komplett kein wort
doch als ich finde man sieht es total
ich finde man fühlt dass auch wenn man
so die unterschiedlichen kommersant die
ja wie kann das denn sein passwort aber
wir haben schon mal eine überraschung ja
und im duell burger king und macos 10
boys gegen sebastian stützt meinst du
nur für die färbung kleine rote okay
aber im ersten blick mag es mich schon
gut ausgetrickst muss ich sagen da habe
ich mich entschieden habe ich einfach
nichts von gekauft und jetzt hast du mir
was max das nächste was ich dem mann
geben beide persönlich chicken nuggets
die beiden product is ok ihr könnt ja
selbst mal entscheiden was ihr findet
das optisch anspruchsvoller ist
ansprechender gemacht es ist einfach so
damit du es nicht unterscheiden kann
werde ich dir einfach hinhalten
das ist aber nur ein beispiel beginnen
wir mit dem ersten und das ist die
nummer eins leute bin echt gespannt also
ich glaub ich weiß es nicht man sicher
leute aber ich glaube auf dem bad keinen
sesam drauf oder wieso was also ist es
geschmeckt müssen wir nur wissen wer das
nicht macht
wobei ich habe eigentlich ich habe oft
genug mckesson ich bin ganz normal das
war der menschen ab und zu auf facebook
das nicht so oft aber das muss man
einfach wissen
das ist der nächste bürger da ist auf
jeden fall zusammen drauf viel geiler
raketenmann hat man den käse gar nicht
geschmeckt soße ist geil und ich falsch
ist dass ich in die kommentare geld
werde von vielen experten wieder sagen
hier bist du beschissener alter jeder
weiß dass saison auf den bürgern hat der
bürger der mir besser geschmeckt hat war
definitiv damit sehr geschmeckt und sage
ich der saison bekommen bis working
daran dass mcdonald's ganz genau kann ja
und ganz wichtig bevor er weiter machen
und vor zwei drei tagen ist eine
nagelneue folge was geht auf dem
unitymedia kanal angekommen das war
ultra fertig bin extra für diese folge
nach gri
im land geflogen nach athen und hab da
so ein streetart künstler getroffen so
ziemlich aller der korrektes menschen
die ich jemals getroffen habe und wir
mal richtig richtig gerne folge daraus
gemacht wie ist jetzt auch erneute
erster linke der beschreibung führt euch
dahin von berlin auf dem was es geht
kann er seit gerne auch abonnieren denn
da haben wir jede woche leisten videos
für euch raus und jetzt war damit mein
medium okay leute die nächsten sachen
liegen bereit sind hier auf den tellern
verteilen ich weiß nicht könnt ihr
optischen unterschied entscheiden sehen
was auch immer gibt es nämlich anders
gemacht leute wir zeigen euch jetzt auch
während ich erwarte nicht was wasser ist
natürlich erst mal gucken ob es irgendwo
optisch erkennt ganz kurz was dann bist
du gut und ich glaube chicken nuggets
bin ich drin weil ich so oft und ich
glaube auch dass man das am
eindeutigsten schmeckt also ich mach mir
den geschmack nämlich mag kann ich
ziemlich gut ok brauche ich weiß habe
ich mal rein ich weiß ja nicht mal eine
safety safe sein kann dass hier sind mac
ist schick mc dassow wenn ich unrecht
hab ich mal recht eine armada das worauf
du gezeigt hast einfach nur ein leerer
teller natürlich schon sagen also
probieren wollte den geschmacks
vergleich konnte aber hört sich -
brillanten essays anders und concept
erster punkt für mac ist aber in
geschmacks bereich also die ersten 2
gegen ja beide anlagen bürger meilenweit
und form ist sondern ich muss sagen mal
schicken lagert geht der geschmacks
punkt auch burger king war scheiße so
leute die nächste sache ist vorbereitet
und diesmal dass sich jedoch im burger
handelt habe ich eine kleine vorkehrung
ich habe einfach die saison gerne von
den bürgern für bürger über st
ich hätte gar wieder auf und wir
beginnen mit dem ersten bürger vor ich
bin echt gespannt ob es erwarten kannst
das ding ist diesmal sebastian ist
eigentlich keine schicken wirkung ich
weiß das ist das eine ganz neue nummer
hier sehr süß sehr scharf mein erster
gedanke zum ersten ist mcdonald's sieht
hier ganz unterschiedliches russen der
dkb dass wir sie nicht erkennen wann der
2 was ist von der soester braucht also
nur hält an alle burger king es sei also
ich bin jetzt ein bisschen der erstes
mcdonald's und der zweites projekt
berichtet richtig
richtig die soja ist kein wunder dass du
es nicht mag mayonnaise
dann kommen wir auch mal eben zum
letzten mal den getränken nach dir sowas
dass ich ein bisschen beruhigt habe ich
mich jetzt nicht und damit leute sind
wir beim finale angekommen eine sache
die wahrscheinlich in beiden fällen
nicht am jeweiligen konzern hergestellt
wird sondern von coca cola angeblich
haben sich bei den beiden getränken und
cola light und auch hier werde ich das
jetzt mal hinhalten und du probierst den
unterschied zu erschmecken das hier ist
das erste männerteam flacher geschmack
also relativ schal irgendwie so nicht so
nicht so krass findet und nummer 24
geiler alter wirklich viel frecher als
auch das so und auch mal erotisch ist
ein scheiß durch hat jetzt das zweite
mal ziemlich viel frischer das andere
forscher ohne wirz bilde ich mir das
jetzt ein das kann ich mir das erste und
direkt hinterher meine zweite ja die
ganze 1000 auf frisch auf 1000 micro
schaffen wo habe ich die geile cola
light gehabt sebastian skoda leichtfried
ich bin cool und zurück die das nicht
mehr lust die leute also ich sage das
erste was mir gegeben hast erinnert mich
vom geschmack her mehr an die cola light
ich bei mcdonald's gehabt habe und ich
sage das zweite was mir gegeben hast ist
burger king meist einfach irgendwie
intensiver ist es so ich komm rüber
wiebels der burger king fanboy aber ich
weiß nicht mit mir geredet mich dass mir
in berga kindes rechter du hast diese
sache richtig erraten darf hier war
burger king dach mcdonagh schlossgarten
krass dass es so einen unterschied macht
wie kann das sein dass cola light anders
schmeckt bei unterschiedlichen leben
vollkommen ich muss sagen diese
geschmacks ist um rauszufinden ob burger
king anders als mcdonald's schmeckt ist
bisschen ausgeartet dahin dass ich zum
ich bin schon ein bisschen zu viel
geworden herzen also leute die in keiner
form irgendwie der head ist es keine
werbung ist einfach nur jetzt einfach
blind getestet und scheinbar schmeckt
sogar die cola light anders leute
kommentiert jetzt mal mit entweder
hashtag tk oder helferteam mcdonald's
oder einsteckt
wenn ihr kein von den dreien mögen würde
er wenn ihr euch halt gesund ernährt das
weiß ich fertig bin sagt danke mit der
kamera und